c'est le président en s'adressant l'été
dernier aux Ukrainiens depuis la tribune
du Parlement ukrainien vous avez dit à
très juste titre que l'âme européenne et
les idéaux sont réalisés aujourd'hui par
un carnet aujourd'hui par le peuplein
notre hymne national a une ligne
importante
nous donnerons notre âme et nos corps
pour notre liberté et nous prouverons
frères que nous sommes de la ligne
cosaque en effet la liberté et notre
idéal est la vie dans une grande et
libre famille européenne
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs nous
atteindrons notre objectif sans aucun
doute nous gagnerons sans aucun doute
quand un vérité de notre côté il nous
reconstruirons sans aucune doute
l'Ukraine libre et indépendante n'avons
pas le droit de perdre notre chance
historique
je vous remercie de votre
et vive la France
[Applaudissements]
merci